hello and welcome to this video playing
Alexa wow I've got a terrible score i
handsome minus 42 wins six losses I
think I remember some very drastic loss
recently let's see what happens yeah
there this smile Hall a three year
that's an uncommon move interesting
though
I should actually I have to take on g4
of course ah [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] just played
this far too quickly CD form ah shoot ah
no now it's not like I'm losing here but
this is a yeah it's not what I wanted
see if I have to take on d4 of course a
stupid move water move order blunder I
know this is a very uncomfortable line
with white having the bishop pair yeah i
mean what gets the bishop pair quite
often in the dems orbit um this is a
very a pretty bad version don't want to
go my own a b2 b6 by writing i get to to
be six just a better square
yeah but really it's it's it's bad but
no no no need to get desperate yet
he gets to defy but I have some ideas
myself um question is how exactly do I
play I don't want to put the bishop on
b7 that's just a bad square a bit after
95 this is threat against b6 maybe I can
play with Bishop d7 nuts my idea is a
possible counter play with night f4 yep
prevented that okay
yeah 94 was my idea here age 5 is very
annoying though
now really hate those simple mistakes in
the opening just have to take or d 4 1st
right now you're sitting here in a bad
position here now that I've found
surprising that he actually allows this
now that's very loose is that really
okay maybe knight on d5 is equals a good
p.m. definitely is
ok
yeah and so he might you might get this
but it's still as I said it's it's
rather rather loose and I was thinking
at five which had also weakens my
position quite a bit yeah it is Roxy aid
I don't have anything really absolutely
not
Fisher 23 is covering all them entry
squares approx I should have just had a
fruit plate something with f5 might
might have not been objectively correct
but the way it turned out it's just just
a disaster
i might play him to through k1 I don't
know I could have played Roxy two year
why didn't I do that okay i can go Ruby
to time warning
hmm
transfer rook CC three I also go to see
60 disaster that game is a pretty
disaster
check
aru k 7 as it's also it's not just lost
it also easily lost this thing sergeant
hard to even even imagine a blunder by
YT I can take f4 and something just just
made on a jade checkmate I have as
sometimes have problems when I will now
make a stupid opening mistake to focus
because I always feel like I'm just
spoiling everything from from the get-go
cd95 is just rubbish of course i have to
take here and then it's a normal
position i am stupid now then you get
get this and it's it's a normal main
line and here white gets the bishop and
quite favorable circumstances because
some well i only have bad alternatives
this is a bad position with whites pawn
structure being pretty fluid and you
have you have the bishops en for nothing
and the way I played it is a different
way of giving him the bishop pair it's
both bad all rights both unfavorable and
this position that's just sucks it just
sucks white has clearly better position
and yeah I don't know it's just a nap
will struggle the way it went and it was
a very clear win it's absolutely nothing
going on maybe I had a look-see to add
one point here like after this but it
also doesn't help
check check now I just don't get totally
killed in this game it's a very bad
opening really bad this is just complete
rubbish just have to take him and then
you're suffering with this with this
rotten position now probably five isn't
great anyway I have to take a call yeah
thanks for watching